parce que nos villes se transforme
perpétuellement nous avons le devoir de
recycler tous ces matériaux yprema votre
partenaire pour un développement durable
bonjour et bienvenue dans équilibre le
magazine de l'environnement et du
développement durable
au sommaire de ce numéro la valade
thermique est une des étapes pour voir
si notre foyer à des pertes d'énergie
nous allons participer à l'une d'entre
elles pour découvrir les solutions à
apporter une association illinoise
nombre de cas liés de solidaires pour
aider les agriculteurs de l'ain et saint
quentinois
nous les avons rencontrés les sangliers
chevreuils sont responsables des
dégradations dans les forêts mais aussi
dans nos propriétés l'office national de
la forêt organise chaque année des
battues pour réguler leur population
la rénovation énergétique ce sont ces
travaux que l'on fait pour réduire nos
factures d'énergie mais avant de les
entreprendre il faut identifier les
pertes de chaleur d'un logement
c'est le but des balades thermique de
l'alec nous en avons suivi une caisse
que qu'est ce qu'on remarque qu est ce
qu on voit de l'intéressant sur cette
maison on se promène déjà sur la façade
on a des points chauds alors voilà au
niveau de la fenêtre
cette caméra thermique révèle ce qui est
invisible à l'oeil nu les défauts
d'isolation de cette maison la meilleure
période pour faire ce type d' analyse
c'est l'hiver c'est là où les
différences sont plus importantes pour
bien voir les déperditions faut une dans
l'idée à 10 degrés de différence
donc on pourrait défaire en été il
suffit juste de les chauffer la maison
35 quand il fait 20 dehors ou 25 on a en
a 10 degrés d'écart mais bon je fais de
la maison à 35 ans était alors que
l'hiver ça se fait tout seul
la caméra voit le problème est derrière
il ya trois-quatre explication possible
il faut creuser les fuites de chaleur
proviennent de différents endroits dans
une maison non isolé les fenêtres
peuvent laisser échapper jusqu'à 15% de
chaleur les murs eux de 20 à 25%
les plus grosses fuites
provenir du toit avec 25 à 30% de pair
mais avant d'envisager les gros travaux
des astuces peuvent être retrouvés si on
n'a pas les moyens de changer une
fenêtre
par exemple si on reste les fenêtres
c'est pas faire tomber des rideaux de
vent dans le cadre parce que c'est un
endroit où il ya un échange de de
chaleur qui se fait on peut avoir des
petits courants d'air constant des
foires 1 qu'en passant la main le long
de la fenêtre donc des rideaux ça reste
un coup froid efficace autre solution
déroule aux isolants dans les combles
perdus ou la protection des tuyaux dans
les pièces non chauffés pour les gros
travaux comme le remplacement des portes
et fenêtres par exemple les solutions de
financement existent comme celle de l'
agence nationale de l'amélioration de
l'habitat et l'aide habiter mieux
suivant vos revenus entre 35% et 50% ce
qui représente 7000 à 10000 euros de
financement sur le montant global est
une condition obtenir au minimum un gain
de 25% sur vos factures d'énergie
d'autres moyens de financement existent
ils sont référencés sur le site du
ministère du développement durable
nous sommes ici à magny les hameaux avec
améliorée aujourd'hui un jour vous êtes
membre du bureau du bonheur est dans le
pré est ce que vous pouvez nous en
parler alors le bonheur est dans le pré
est une association de type loi 1901
notre objectif c'est d'aider des
agriculteurs à financer leurs projets
alors nous ne sommes pas une banque nous
sommes une association c'est un prêt qui
est solidaire donc on gagne pas d'argent
dessus c'est à 0%
la cagnotte s'est créé l'année dernière
lorsque le maraîcher qui livrait
plusieurs amap du territoire donc 2 à
guyancourt et una à magny les hameaux
plus celle qui est un peu plus loin
qu'ils aient à en beauce a a connu des
difficultés passagères de trésorerie
donc la banque n'est pas très prêteuses
dans ce contexte et on s'est tous
mobilisés en disant il ya un agriculteur
qui livrent des paniers qui est sur le
territoire
donc on a essayé de l'aider via une
cagnotte solidaire donc on a créé cette
cagnotte l'année dernière nous avons
réussi à lever un premier prêt de dix
mille euros pour cet agriculteur puis un
deuxième de 2500 euros pour qu'ils
puissent acheter un semoir vous parlez
de cagnotte
oui comment ça fonctionne vous
déterminez un montant avec l'agriculteur
tout à fait alors souvent l'agriculteur
vient pour
nous parler de son projet qu'est ce
qu'il a à faire il ya quelques ou alors
comme nous sommes pas une banque nous on
se limite on ne dépasse pas les somme de
10000 euros au dessus ça devient très
compliqué à gérer mais si c'est par
exemple pour des l'achat de matériel ou
etc
on peut les années claire peuvent se
tourner vers nous et pour les gens qui
sont intéressés
qu'est ce que c'est c'est un don ou
c'est un prénom alors c'est un prêt donc
certes à 0% donc ils gagneront pas
d'argent dessus mais ça reste un prêt
après si des personnes veulent faire des
dons bien évidemment c'est possible mais
c'est à voir directement avec
l'agriculteur ou le producteur
donc c'est un prêt en matière de
fonctionnement pour pouvoir prêter il
faut que la personne soit membre de
l'association ils prêtent cet argent à
l'association qui elle fait le pré donc
voilà et toutes les personnes sont
remboursés à la fin du prêt quand la
cagnotte
elle-même a reçu l'argent ces cagnottes
si on est là aujourd'hui c'est parce
qu'il y en a deux qui se lancent la
première concerne robert pires un marche
un maraîcher de magny les hameaux je
vous propose avant qu'on en parle de
regarder un petit portrait qu'on a fait
chez lui pour le moment il n'y a pas
grand chose à voir
auparavant dans l'industrie robert pirès
décide il ya quatre ans de changer
d'activité pour le maraîchage
ça demandait plus de temps que cela plus
de difficultés pour vraiment validé
l'envi d'enfer d'en faire mon métier
c'est devenu plus qu'une passion faite
puisque petit à petit ou d'un an ou deux
ans
en ne formant et bien j'ai eu envie d'en
fait de ne pas faire autre chose que sa
retenue par un comité de sélection
regroupant la commune de magny
l'agglomération saint-quentinoise le
parc naturel de la haute vallée de
chevreuse et le groupement à biot sol
robert pirès lance petit à petit son
activité de maraîchers j'ai commencé des
semis de graines dans des petites notes
chez des amis à maresché qu'il l'aimait
qu'ils les gardent au chaud et au mois
de mars des plans très ici dans des
tunnels du maraîcher puis à partir du
mois d'avril les plantations se feront
dehors avec le avec le beau temps et le
printemps qui sera revenu ce samedi la
solidarité s'activent pour l'aider à
s'installer
mais pour travailler dans les meilleures
conditions robert pires a besoin
d'équipements agricoles coûteux et
notamment un tracteur c'est un
investissement important en fête
agricole on peut considérer que l'on
s'installe avec avec un investissement
d'environ 150000 euros et donc toute
aide financière
surtout quand elle vient de la base des
consommateurs des citoyens français très
important
on a un objectif d'atteindre 10 mille
euros de prêts
ce serait super d'atteindre ce montant
là déjà robert pirès espère sortir ses
premiers légumes au mois de mai il ne
reste plus qu'à attendre
il y à une deuxième cagnotte qui
concerne un apiculteur est ce que pour
me parler un peu de lui
oui tout à fait alors il s'agit de
julien perrin qui est apiculteur aux
molières et qui livrent plusieurs amap
notamment celle de manille qui s'appelle
le panier des hameaux dont qui libre en
miel cette amap et il se trouve qu'il a
besoin de financement pour moderniser sa
miellerie notamment l'achat de matériel
comme une pompe à miel donc il a un
besoin d'à peu près 5000 euros julien
perrin justement nous l'avons suivi lors
d'une de ses livraisons
je vous propose qu'on les écoute
maintenant mon exploitation s est tourné
avant de travailler qu'une fondation de
manière bénévole pour multiplier des
abeilles naturellement résistantes
ce travail bénévole il permet pas de
faire vivre mon exploitation et du coup
pour le maintenir j'ai besoin de
mécaniser une partie de mon exploitation
pour dégager du temps pour pouvoir
garder cette activité lorsque bart ans
pour mettre du miel en po1 miel de
printemps qui va être créée me c'est
très très long et il n'y a pas beaucoup
de valeur ajoutée de mettre en mots le
miel soi même et donc du coup il ya
dépendre des pompes qui permettent de
doser la dose qu'on va mettre dans les
po et qui amène le miel avec force et du
coup ça permet de gagner beaucoup de
temps
on vient de voir les deux récoltes qui
sont et qui vont être organisées est ce
que vous pouvez me donner la date de fin
de ses récoltes
alors on s'est dit que ce serait bien
d'avoir tout récupérer pour fin février
après où on récupère ce que les gens
veulent bien veulent bien prêter
donc si on atteint le montant tant mieux
si on l'atteint pas on donnera la somme
on traitera la somme qu'on aura réussi à
récolter le montant est libre oui tout à
fait les gens donnent enfin prête plus
exactement ce qu'ils veulent
il faut pas faut pas hésiter même si
c'est que 10 euros de 10 euros en 10
euros ça peut aller ça peut aller très
vite on est pas on demande pas que les
gens prêtent près de 200 euros parce que
financièrement c'est peut-être compliqué
donc ils font presque il va lui et ben
merci et qu'améliorer pour toutes ces
explications la merci de votre accueil
le surpeuplement des sangliers et des
chevreuils entraîne des dégradations
dans les bois mais aussi dans nos
propriétés toujours plus proche des
forêts pour réguler leur population
l'office national des forêts organise
chaque année des battues reportage vous
respectez les angles de tir ont tiré
tout animal sorti de la drac en
respectant les 30 degrés ils sont 24
chasseurs être là en forêt de port-royal
24 avoir répondu à l'appel de l'office
national des forêts leur objectif
abattre sangliers et chevreuils présent
en trop grand nombre pour le chevreuil
les chasseurs ne peuvent pas dépasser le
nombre de 27 sur la saison pour le
sanglier c'est une toute autre histoire
il n'y a pas de limitation nous ce que
l'on cherche à éliminer
c'est le maximum de d'animaux parce
qu'on sait pertinemment que de toute
façon on n'arrivera pas à éradiquer de
cet animal se reproduit très vite du
pays mais trop bas jusqu'à 10 avant la
dernière fois une mère une les parts par
saison par année sachant qu'il ya
plusieurs mises bas par an les chasseurs
se répartissent en groupe
les tireurs seront 15 avec à leur tête
des responsables
les chefs de ligne je vais chef de ligne
donc je vais m'occuper d'une ligne de
poster le tout c'est de fermer une
enceinte donc là en l'occurrence aurait
fermé le carré de la belle toise nous
allons mettre trois lignes de miradors
contre les miradors c'est pour tyr en
sécurité en les gens vont respecter un
certain nombre de d'angle de tir est
donc là moi je vais poster 4 5 personnes
sur leurs miradors aligné en répliquant
où ils doivent tirer ou pas
les traqueurs sont au nombre de neuf
avec leurs chiens ils sont chargés de
rabattre les animaux ces chasseurs sont
armés nenê tire pas
on y est quelques minutes à peine après
le début de la traque le premier animal
et débusquer alors celui ci pèse près de
80 kg sur cette journée les chasseurs
ont abattu trois sangliers et un
chevreuil sur le massif de trappes la
chasse se pratique sur cinq journées de
novembre à février
avant nous quitter noter ces quelques
rendez vous la maison de l'environnement
propose une exposition autour des
planches pédagogiques de la maison
deyrolle ses planches lancé en 1831 est
destiné à un public scolaire à ben les
enjeux environnementaux et sociétaux
contemporain elles sont à découvrir
jusqu'au 28 février
les beaux jours arrivent c'est
l'occasion de prendre soin les uns des
autres routiers l'association jardins
passions partage anime un atelier pour
découvrir les bons gestes à adopter
rendez vous le 28 février et pour les
enfants si vous avez envie de créer un
nourrison à oiseaux ou de fabriquer vos
propres jus de pomme
la ferme de gally de saint cyr propose
des ateliers pendant les vacances
scolaires
voilà équilibre c'est terminé je vous
donne rendez vous le mois prochain et
d'ici là pensez à faire un geste pour
l'environnement